strident convolutions is another piece
of the basic building block of
convolutions as used in convolutional
neural networks let me show you an
example let's say you want to convert
this seven by seven image with this D by
three filter except that instead of
doing in the usual way we're going to do
it with a stride of two what that means
is you take the element wise product as
usual in this upper left V by three
region and then multiply an ad and that
gives you ninety one but then instead of
stepping the blue box over by one step
we're going to step it over by two steps
so we're gonna make it hop over two
steps like so notice how the upper
left-hand corner has gone from dis dot
to dis stopped jumping over one position
and then you do the usual element wise
product and summing and that gives you
it turns out one hundred and now we're
going to do that again and make the blue
box jump over by two steps so you end up
there and that gives you eighty three
and now when you go to the NICS row you
again actually take two steps instead of
one step so going to move the blue box
over there notice how we're skipping
over one of the positions and then just
gives you 69 and now you gain step over
two steps this gives you 91 and so on
this 127 and then for the final row 44
72 and 74 so in this example we convolve
with a 7 by 7 matrix with a 3 by 3
matrix and we get a 3 by 3 output so the
input and output dimensions turns out to
be governed by the following formula if
you have an N by n image they involved
with an F by F filter and if you use
padding P and stride s so in this
example s is equal to 2 then you end up
with an output
that is n plus 2 P minus F and now
because you're stepping s steps at the
time this of just one step at a time you
know you you now divided by s plus one
and then by the same thing so in our
example we have 7 plus 0 minus 3 divided
by 2
let's try plus 1 equals let's see that's
4 over 2 plus 1 equals 3 which is why we
wound up with this V by 3 Oakland now
just one last detail which is 1 of this
fraction is not an integer in that case
we're going to round this down so this
notation denotes the 4 of something so
this right this is also called the floor
of Z it means taking Z and rounding down
to the nearest integer and if the way
this is implemented is that you take
this type of blue box multiplication the
only of the blue box is fully contained
within the image or the image posted
having and if any of this blue box kind
of part of it hangs outside and you just
do not do that computation then it turns
out that if that's a convention that
you're you know 3 by 3 filter must lie
entirely within your image or the image
plus the having region before there's a
corresponding output generator if that's
convention then the right thing to do
for the to computing output dimension is
to round down in case this n plus 2 P
minus F over s is not an integer so just
to summarize the dimensions if you have
an N by n matrix or n by n image that
you convolved with an F by F matrix and
that by a filter repair a phys then the
output size will have this dimension
and you know it is nice we can choose
all of these numbers so that that isn't
integer although sometimes you don't
have to do that and rounding down this
is just fine as well but please feel
free to work through a few examples of
values of n F P and s for yourself to
convince yourself if you want that this
formula is correct for the output size
now before moving on there is a
technical comment I want to make about
cross correlations versus the
convolutions and this won't affect what
you have to do to implement
convolutional neural networks but
depending on if you read a different
math textbook or signal processing
textbook there is one other possible
inconsistency in the notation which is
that if you look at a typical math
textbook the way that the convolution is
defined before doing the element wise
product and summing there's actually one
other step that you would first take
which is to convolve this 6x6 matrix of
the 3x3 filter you would first take the
3x3 filter and flip it on the horizontal
as well as the vertical axis so this 3 4
5 102 - 197 would become the egos here
4 goes there 5 goes there and then the
second row becomes this 102 minus 1 9 7
but this is really taking the 3 by 3
filter and mirroring it both on the
vertical and the horizontal axis and
then it was this flipped matrix that you
would then copy over here so to compute
the output you would take 2 times 7 plus
3 times 2 plus 7 times 5 and so on right
and you actually multiply out the
elements of this flipped matrix in order
to compute the upper left-hand most
element of the you know of the 4x4
output
as follows and then you take those nine
numbers and your ship them over by one
ship them over by one and so on so the
way we've defined the convolution
operation in these videos is that we've
skipped this mirroring operation and
technically what we're actually doing
really the operation we've been using
for the last three videos is sometimes
crowd cross-correlation instead of
convolution but in the deep learning
literature by convention we just call
this a convolution operation so just to
summarize by convention in machine
learning we usually do not bother with
this flipping operation and technically
this operation is maybe better called
cross-correlation but most of the deep
learning literature just causes the
convolution operator and so I'm going to
use that convention in these videos as
well and if you read a lot of the
machine learning literature you find
most people just call this the
convolution operator without bothering
to use these flips and it turns out that
in signal processing or in certain
branches of mathematics doing the
flipping in the definition of
convolution calls this convolution
operator to enjoy this property that a
convolve would be involved with C is
equal to a involved would be involved
with C and this is called associativity
in mathematics and this is nice for some
signal processing applications but for
deep neural networks it really doesn't
matter and so omitting this double
mirroring operation just simplifies the
code and mixing your own integral work
just as well and by convention most of
us just call this convolution even
though the mathematicians prefer to call
this cross correlation sometimes but
this should not affect anything you have
to implement in the program exercises
and should not affect your ability to
read and understand the deep learning
literature
so you've now seen how to carry out
convolutions and you've seen how to use
heading as well strides for convolutions
but so far all we've been using is
convolutions / matrices like / 6x6
matrix in the next video you see how to
carry out convolutions / volumes and
this will make what you can do with
convolutions suddenly much more powerful
let's go onto the next video